[Music]
ah
food one of life's great pleasures
whether you're an organism whose body
can create its own food or you
make do with the consumption of other
organisms food
sustains and connects life both large
and
small but we're not going to talk about
food today
we're going to talk about what happens
after
no great meal comes without consequences
even photosynthetic microbes produce
oxygen they don't need a byproduct
that is quite useful to many other
organisms including
us and for organisms that have to digest
their
food to extract nutrients well there's
all sorts of stuff
left behind when the process is done in
the world
of the micro cosmos there are not only
many
varied tiny organisms there are also
many
varied ways to produce even
tinier poop
[Music]
and when we say tinier we mean it
if you're worried about being grossed
out by this video or you
really want to make sure you're not
missing anything just know that some of
this pooping will require you to pay
very close attention
some of this will probably look similar
to macroscopic bowel movements and
some will seem less so so let's start
with the more poop-like poop that comes
from some of the multi-cellular members
of the micro cosmos particularly the
ones with digestive systems complete
with specialized regions for digesting
food
and releasing solid waste
our dragon like friend the gastric trick
is doing the old scrunchian poop
probably after having finished a nice
meal made up of bacteria or protozoa
the food that came in through its
pharynx
was then sent through the intestine a
straight tube
full of digestive cells after the
remains continued
their way to the end of the tube where
lies
the anus a microscopic gateway
out of the gastritric and into the world
that's all well and good for the more
complex organisms but
how does one poop when one does not have
a butthole
well for some single-celled organisms
one
becomes the butthole
such is the case for amoebas their
formlessness
allows them to easily shift their shape
around
to take in food via phagocytosis
the amoeba here happens to have found a
nice
meal made of a ciliate which is now
contained in a food vacuole
filling with digestive enzymes those
enzymes will eventually break the cilia
down allowing the amoeba to absorb
nutrients
into its cytoplasm but then what happens
with the remains
well as we see with this amoeba here it
gets
released amoebas and other similar
organisms
use a process called exocytosis
to send waste back to the membrane where
it is removed from their body
[Music]
you can see this again here in this
mastic amoeba
slowly gliding along the microscope
slide
while a round bit seems to come off up
top
it almost looks like it's leaving behind
a little piece of itself which
i mean maybe it is
ciliates have a more refined approach to
pooping
which is to say they have the
unicellular equivalent of an anus
called a cytoproct ciliates
gather food into an oral groove
and then consume it in the digestive
vacuoles that travel through the cell
eventually when the vacuole makes its
way to the cytoplast
the contents get out and there you have
cilia poop
the way organisms poop the way microbes
poop are even
more varied and wonderful than we've
been able to show you here but you might
be wondering
how you get from something relatively
simple like this ciliate releasing a
small bit of waste to something more
complex
like this tardigrade with its more
compartmentalized approach to defecation
well the answer of course is evolution
but it's an answer that leads
to many more unanswered questions even
within
animals the evolution of the anus or in
some species the cloaca
is not well understood as discussed in a
2015 review paper with the spectacular
title
getting to the bottom of anal evolution
while the anus itself is linked to the
evolution of a digestive system
not all metazoans have a designated
anus the hydra gut has only one opening
which means that the organism's mouth
has to
pull digestive double duty and open back
up to release the waste
and how that system fits in with the
evolution of digestion
overall is unclear much like the
evolution of sex
anuses are a trait that appears and
disappears in evolutionary lineages
reflecting the fact that they might be
useful for some animals and less so for
others
the duality of the hydra's mouth seems
to be working out great for them after
all
but having a digestive system with a
distinct entrance
and exit is pretty handy too
for one it's just a little less
disgusting but it also
keeps food flowing in one direction and
that means
animals like the tardigrade and us don't
have to wait
to finish digesting to eat more food
that would be annoying we just get to
keep eating
all thanks to that evolutionary mystery
that
is the anus
[Music]
in the end though anus are not everybody
poops
food after all might be one of life's
great pleasures but all good things
must come to an end and perhaps
with the micro cosmos we can find some
pleasure in that
as well thank you for coming on this
journey with us
as we explore the unseen world that
surrounds us
it's been quite a while since we did a
video answering some of your
most frequently asked questions so we
would like to let you know that we're
going to be doing another one of those
soon if you have any questions that
you'd like us to answer in that video
please leave them in the comments or you
can tweet us your questions at
journey2micro or leave them for us on
our patreon
and yes all of the people on the screen
right now those
are our patrons they are the people that
make this show possible so if you want
to be one of them you can go to
patreon.com
journey to micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes
james weiss check out jam and germs on
instagram
and if you want to see more from us
there's probably a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
you